Well
hello, how are you, I'm Andrés González with your
brief informative report from IU News Nao in
Spanish. This news has been in development
since Thursday morning. One person and
three dogs lost their lives after a
fire in a mobile home. This
incident occurred near the Sahara and
slowly.  Authorities said they
came to the home hours earlier due to
reports of an argument.
Detectives are now on the trail of a
suspect. Police believe the
victim is a female. The incident is
still under investigation.
to offer vaccines against the
virus for the most recent eligible group,
we are talking about children between
5 and 11 years of age, the dose for
children is only one third of that
applied to adults. For all the
details, you can visit our
news page.  now dotcom the section in
Spanish
Happy Veterans Day Today we
pay tribute to all the men and women
who served in the military  ar of
our country this annual parade in
downtown begins at 10 in the morning
and today is special because after two
years it is celebrated due to the pandemic
this will be about ford and gas and continues
until stuart to bening
now we will see the forecast of the
weather today we will have a day
reaching 77 degrees the temperatures will rise
for the weekend around 80 there
will be some clouds and winds by the
middle of next week have
a nice day cheers andrés gonzález
with about the news from iu news now
in  Spanish